من الرياض ينضم لنا رئيس قسم الفن في
جريده رياض الناقد عبد الرحمن الناصر اهلا
بكم في مسائل العربيه ورمضان كريم
رمضان كريم عليك اهلا بك طب بعد انتصاف
حلقات الاعمال الدراميه الخليجيه في رمضان
كيف رايتها اولا ما بين المحتوى والانتاج
ومستوى تنافس بين هذه الدراما
والله بلا شك يعني اليوم في نهضه على
المستوى العربي يعني لانه في الخليج يعني
ما زلنا نحاول ان نصنع شيء اعتمدنا على
على الجيل القديم
بلا شك طاش ما طاش يعني او طاش العوده
يعني يتصدر المشهد عوده ناصر وعبد الله
بعدين قطاع 12 سنه يعني ساهم مساهمه فعاله
في متابعه العمل
الخليجي الله يسامحك يا استاذ عبد الرحمن
التنوع
عشان كنا نتطرق لهذا الموضوع بالتفصيل
بالجزء الثاني
تفضل يلا
[موسيقى]
نرجع لو ما عندك مشكله
بشكل عام يعني لا يليق
لا يليق بمستوى ثقافه
[موسيقى]
والعلم الذي دائما يبحثون
المشاهد اليوم المشاهد ذو ثقافه عاليه
بالتالي تجدينه دائما يبحث عن سفر برلك
يبحث عن عن المحتوى الدرامي المصري عن
المحتوى الدرامي
السوري او اللبنان طيب استاذ عبد الرحمن
انت كنت عم تحكي من شوي عن عوده الثنائي
ناصر القصبي وعبد الله السدحان بس انا بدي
اسالك انه هل تتوقع انت شخصيا استمرار
لطاش في المواسم القادمه
والله هو لابد ان يستمر لانه لانه يعتبر
قطاع 12 سنه يعني
سنوات مجحفه ما بين ما بين النجمين يعني
تخيلي انه هؤلاء النجمين لم يلتقوا في اي
عمل طوال 12 سنه اليوم التقوا كونوا
انفسهم من جديد
يحاولوا ان يعيدوا وجدانيات المشاه
السعودي او المشاهد العربي على على نطاق
واسع يعني انا اتمنى
ومتاكد انه هذه التجربه لن تكون الوحيده
انما ستكون تجارب اخرى وهذا هو المامون
طيب سيدي عبد الرحمن منه ولدنا عمل حظيه
باصداء واسعه في الجزء الاول ويعود هذا
الموسم بجزء الثاني كيف تشاهد تجربه هذه
الدراما
هي هي
تجربه جميله يعني انت تعرفين اليوم
ابراهيم
الحجاج اليوم اصبح من احد نجوم الصف الاول
على مستوى الخليج وبالتالي
المتابعين والمشاهدين يبحثون عن ما يقدم
ابراهيم الحجاز سواء على مستوى الدراما او
السينما او ايا كان او ظهوره حتى في
الحوارات التقليديه نتوقع انه من هو ولدنا
عمل دينامي ديناميكي
يساهم ايضا في في جذب المشاهد استاذ عبد
الرحمن بشكل عام وبكل صراحه هل ترى بان
الدراما الخليجيه في تحسن مع هذا الزخم من
الاعمال وهذه المنافسه الكبيره نتحدث عن
اعمال سوريه اعمال مصريه هل باعتقادك بان
الاعمال الخليجيه في رمضان تنافس وتتفوق
على الاعمال العربيه الاخرى من جنسيه غير
خليجيه
لا ما اعتقد لانه لانه اليوم احنا احنا في
في محيط نامل الان ان ننافس بعض وبالتالي
نظهر لننافس الاخرين اليوم الدراما
المصريه على مستوى عالي جدا من التنوع
تجدينها في
الدراما التاريخيه تجرينها في
الدراما الاجتماعيه
التراثيه ايضا
الكوميديانيه ايضا
الدراما السوريه رغم المشاكل ورغم
الانحدار في المستوى العام الاقتصادي
والحروب
والزلازل الا انهم يقدمون دراما على مستوى
عالي جدا اعتقد انه البون شاسع ما بين
الدراما الخليجيه في الوقت الحالي وما بين
الدراما العربيه الا انه في سفر برلك ربما
هو يتيح لنا فرصه انه نقارن بعض مواهبنا
في على المستوى العربي
شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس قسم الفن في جريده
رياض ناقل لعبد الرحمن ناصر يسعد مساك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات